I got me wanting me
the outfit you had outfits I did I'm a
country girl and we like our wardrobe
changes okay first thing first things
first
winning for gospel album what does that
mean to you and what does that say to
you oh it means so much
um I feel like I've just been super
emotional all night but I love this
album so much and it's something that
I've just always wanted to make and I
got to
um finally and I really did it very
selfishly because I just wanted to sing
these songs and kind of get to live in
that space for a little while and the
fact that it's resonated with people it
just means the world to me
your husband played hockey hockey
players have great legs but the legs
that set the internet on fire tonight
were yours what are you doing what are
you doing
um I mean I I love Fitness
um I do have a fitness app called fit 52
and I practice what I preach so um I
love to work out and it's nothing really
complicated
um things like squats and lunges and
things
like um I do I like to work out I like
feeling strong
you look strong strong I would not race
you right now or what a squad against
you also premiering ghost tonight ghost
story yes
um just so exciting uh to have new music
and there's a lot more to come but
premiering ghost story on their Grammys
I mean how
bigger than that so I was very nervous
but I'm very excited we arrived looking
like country
tell us about that uh Dolce Gabbana have
been wearing that almost all night this
is Dolce Gabbana as well
um but I just put it on and I just felt
like princess so I was like it just
feels right and I'm gonna roll with it
you're a princess and but you still go
home and you gotta be Mama right I know
my kids are actually in my hotel room
right now and they're probably gonna
wake me up but Lord knows what time in
the morning because that's what they've
been doing ever since they got here
um but it's all good
um yeah they probably didn't see the
award show on TV hopefully they better
be in bed
I don't know they might have been
watching Mama congratulations though it
means something to win that gospel it
does more than anybody could ever know
and praise to God and just
I'm just glad I'm here and get to
celebrate now
[Music]